I was scheduled to have a very interesting
interview for you right now and unfortunately,
the guest has very rudely last minute bailed
on us.
And if you only knew who this guest was, Barack
Obama.
No, just kidding.
If you knew who the guest was, you'd be mildly
upset.
That's probably the truth of it.
So in it, in order not to delay the production
of today's show, I'm going to briefly open
up the phone lines and hear from a few people.
We just had the Donald Trump tax return decision,
which I'll be talking about at the end of
the show and much more so.
Let's go to the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero 47 50.
Starting with our caller from the five five
nine area code.
Who's calling today from 555 nine.
Five five nine, are you there, caller from
555 nine.
OK.
Last chance for five five nine and five five
nine is gone.
Let's go to our caller from the two six zero
area code who is calling today from two six
00.
I can you hear me?
Yeah.
Who's this?
I just had a quick question.
I was wondering when you were going to third
and only said sorry when I'm going to start
with an only fans.
You said, yeah.
And only then because I think a great guy
like you would just, you know, really excel
in that scene.
So, you know that you interestingly enough,
this may be shocking to the audience, but
you're not.
What was your name, by the way?
Oh, I just.
You're not the only person Gests, who has
suggested I start and only fans.
But my understanding is it's essentially like
a porn site, isn't it?
Yes.
OK.
And do you want me to start one?
Yeah, I think it'd be great.
OK, I'm on Cameo, but I'm not on only fans
and I don't know that that's gonna change
anytime soon.
I'm sorry to disappoint both men and women,
apparently, who want me to start that, but
I don't see it in my future.
Just.
All right.
Thank you, Gary.
Very good.
Just seemed totally serious there.
That was that that was a serious phone call,
as far as I can tell.
Let's go next to our caller from the seven
one seven area code.
Who's calling today from seven one seven?
Hi, my name's Omar.
Hey, Omar, what's going on?
I live in Pennsylvania and everything's opened
up.
And when I go to the gym, like most people
aren't wearing math and like all the coffee
shop, like they're kind of people just sitting
there working is really like worried about
the spread of the virus.
Now, I feel like concern.
Now, let me ask you this, Omar.
If the gym you've identified as a place that
looks dangerous, why are you going to the
gym?
That's a good question.
I really love the gym and it makes you feel
a lot better.
Yeah.
So I try to go there sparingly when they're
not a lot of people.
Right.
I don't know, like I I'd go maybe like twice
a week.
Normally I would be gone five times a week.
Right back and go in.
No, listen, I understood you are saying my,
um, my gym just e-mailed that they're opening
on Monday and workouts will be limited to
90 minutes, as if that's a problem for me,
right, Omar?
I mean, I'm not spending 90 minutes there,
but, you know, you're going you have to wipe
down every machine between use.
You're not allowed to hang out and talk to
people.
You have to have your temperature taken on.
You know, when I read the list to me, it's
like, oh, yeah, it's clearly way too dangerous.
It's warm right now.
I'll just workout outside or do YouTube workouts
or what.
That's the call I made.
But I'm totally with you.
I would love to be able to safely go to the
gym.
Yeah, it's just disheartening that, like,
no one's wearing my view.
I think it'd be a lot safer.
Everyone wore masks.
Absolutely not.
Absolutely.
So.
Well, listen, I guess all we can do is hope
that it improves.
I did go to a coffee shop last weekend.
And, you know, it's an outdoor seating only
sort of thing.
There were no tables with within 10 feet of
me.
I posted a picture of it on my Instagram.
It that felt safe.
And I think I'm just I'm going to only do
things that feels safe the way that they're
being done in my state.
And so I'll do outdoor dining.
I went and got my haircut, wore a mask the
entire time.
But I'm going to pass on the gym.
I'm in a pass on Indore for now.
All right, my friend, thank you so much for
the call.
Great to hear from you.